This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For the ancient Greeks, sirens were mythical creatures who sang out to passing sailors from rocks in the sea. Their music was so beautiful it was said that sailors were powerless against it. They would turn their ships towards these sea nymphs and crash into the reefs around them. In Homer's Odyssey, there's a story where Odysseus and his men are traveling near an area that sirens are known to inhabit. In Odysseus knows that if he hears the siren song, his ship is going to sink, but he still wants to hear what they sound like, so he comes up with a plan.
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马斯。对于古希腊人来说，塞壬是神话中的生物，它们在海上的礁石上向过往的水手歌唱。它们的歌声如此美妙，据说水手们根本无法抵挡。他们会将船只驶向这些海妖，然后撞毁在周围的暗礁上。在荷马的《奥德赛》中，有一个故事讲述了奥德修斯和他的手下在一个以塞壬出没闻名的海域附近航行。奥德修斯知道，如果他听到塞壬的歌声，他的船就会沉没，但他仍然想听听它们听起来是什么样子的，于是他想出了一个计划。
Odysseus has his men tie him to the mast so that he can't take control of the ship. Then Odysseus has his men fill their own ears with beeswax so they can't hear anything. The plan works. Odysseus gets to hear the sirens call, his men don't, and they sail on to safety, with Odysseus pleading with his crew to crash the boat the whole way. And for over 2,000 years or so, that's what a siren was, a creature that made a beautiful sound. That all changed in 1819, when a French engineer named Charles Cagnard de la Tour decided
奥德修斯让手下把他绑在桅杆上，这样他就无法控制船只。然后，奥德修斯让手下用蜂蜡塞住耳朵，这样他们就什么也听不见了。计划成功了。奥德修斯听到了塞壬的召唤，他的手下没有听到，他们一路安全航行，而奥德修斯一路上都在恳求船员撞毁船只。在两千多年的时间里，塞壬就是这样一种存在——一种发出美妙声音的生物。这一切在1819年发生了改变，当时一位名叫查尔斯·卡格纳德·德·拉·图尔的法国工程师决定
to call the artificial noise maker he was working on. The siren. And this new mechanical siren became one of the signature sounds of the modern world. Sirens warn people about eminent bombing raids during World War I, sirens announce incoming fire engines and ambulances and police. Thanks in part to the siren, the world of the early 20th century had become a lot louder than any time in human history. And we can probably assume that these sirens that people heard in cities all over the world sounded nothing like the siren songs of Greek myth.
给他正在研发的人造噪声发生器起个名字。叫作塞壬。而这个新型机械塞壬成为了现代世界的标志性声音之一。在第一次世界大战期间，塞壬向人们发出即将遭到轰炸的警报；塞壬宣告着消防车、救护车和警车的到来。部分归功于塞壬，20世纪初的世界变得比人类历史上任何时候都要吵闹。我们或许可以推测，世界各地城市人们听到的这些塞壬发出的声音，与希腊神话中的塞壬之歌毫无相似之处。
At least to most people, one man, a composer, named Arseniy Avramov, heard music in the cacophony of the modern world, and he tried to create a composition of symphony from the clatter of the newly formed Soviet Union. In this little bit of a departure from the typical 99% invisible program, Moscow-based producer Charles Mainz investigated the legend of Avramov and his forgotten masterpiece. And then we're going to follow that up with a classic 99% invisible about Soviet design. But first, this is the symphony of sirens, revisited.
至少对大多数人来说是这样。但有一位名叫阿尔谢尼伊·阿夫拉莫夫的作曲家，却在现代世界的喧嚣中听到了音乐，他试图用这个刚刚成立的苏联的嘈杂声创作一部交响乐。本期节目与典型的“99%隐形”节目略有不同，常驻莫斯科的制作人查尔斯·迈因茨调查了关于阿夫拉莫夫及其被遗忘的杰作的传奇故事。接下来，我们将为大家带来一期关于苏联设计的经典“99%隐形”节目。但首先，这是重访《鸣笛交响乐》。
But first, this is the symphony of sirens, revisited. So here's what I know. November of 1923, a man named Arsenio Vramov will climb onto a rooftop in Central Moscow. You will be holding two flags. But the day will be November 7th, and the Soviet Union, the USSR, will be celebrating its sixth anniversary. The birthday of the one and only Bolshevik revolution. This man of Ramavira is a communist. He's also a composer of music, and there on this roof, near the Kremlin,
但首先，这是重访《鸣笛交响乐》。这就是我所知道的。1923年11月，一个名叫阿尔谢尼·阿夫拉莫夫的人将爬上莫斯科市中心的一处屋顶。他手里将拿着两面旗帜。但这一天将是11月7日，苏联（USSR）将庆祝其成立六周年。也就是布尔什维克革命的诞辰。这个叫阿夫拉莫夫的人是个共产主义者。他也是一位音乐作曲家，就在克里姆林宫附近的那个屋顶上，
he will link the two with what might sound like a strange idea. He will conduct a symphony made up of an entire city. He will call this symphony, the symphony of Cyruns. Let's be clear, this isn't his first time. But it will be his most important attempt so far. So be it Big League, so to speak. So this is what I know about a rumble. This is all I know, and I know what I know from a different man.
他将把这两者结合起来，其想法听起来可能有些奇怪。他将指挥一首由整座城市共同演奏的交响乐。他将这部交响乐命名为《鸣笛交响乐》（Symphony of Sirens）。需要说明的是，这并不是他第一次这么做。但这将是他迄今为止最重要的一次尝试。可以说是一次“大联盟”级别的演出。这就是我所知道的关于阿夫拉莫夫的事。这就是我知道的全部，而我的这些知识来源于另一个人。
The man I'm going to see now. His name is Andre Smirnov. He is a man who studies these things, a man who writes about these things. He is a man who can answer what have clearly now become our common questions. Orm so I thought, even Smyrnosa it was impossible the class of Ayavramov. He told me Ayavramov was from a Kassak family and it worked for the circus. He was a fountain of ideas, a lady's man, and if he couldn't be pinned down in his personal life, it was even more so with his work. In one sense they call him a composer. в этом жизни, и он был даже более с ним в его жизни. В принципе, его на зверткомпозитором, да он был композитором.
我现在要去见的那个人。他的名字叫安德烈·斯米尔诺夫。他是一个研究这些事情的人，一个撰写这些事情的人。他是一个能够回答我们现在显然已经共同关心的问题的人。我是这么认为的，尽管斯米尔诺夫也认为要归类阿夫拉莫夫是不可能的。他告诉我，阿夫拉莫夫来自一个哥萨克家庭，曾在马戏团工作。他是一个点子王、妇女之友，如果说他在个人生活中无法被定义的话，那么在工作上就更是如此了。从某种意义上说，人们称他为作曲家。在生活中，他甚至更倾向于此。原则上，他可以说是作曲家，是的，他确实是个作曲家。
В one sense, they call him a composer. Yes, he was a composer. He studied music for a few years. На самом деле, я как, наверно, но я, like most people interested in Abraham, know very little about his music, because almost none of it survived. So you could say there wasхе between his experiments.
从某种意义上说，人们称他为作曲家。是的，他确实是个作曲家。他学了几年的音乐。事实上，就像大多数对阿夫拉莫夫感兴趣的人一样，我对他的音乐知之甚少，因为他的作品几乎没有一首流传下来。所以你可以说，在他的各种实验之间存在着某种断层。
His ideas about the future of music, music that was never written down, and the music he made to survive, the music he made to make money. So, to talk about what kind of music he wrote or would have written, if that music would have survived, well, we've just done now. So, yes, he's a composer, but he's a composer based on myth.
他关于音乐未来的构想——那些从未被写下来的音乐，以及他为了生存而创作的音乐、为了赚钱而创作的音乐。因此，要谈论他到底创作了什么样音乐，或者如果那些音乐流传下来他会创作什么音乐，嗯，我们现在就已经在做了。所以，是的，他是一位作曲家，但一位基于神话的作曲家。
The myth in part was based on a flair for the dramatic. Rion Hietnik named himself Réve Ars Avra, the revolution of Arsenio Ramov. в Ассенеи Ромов. Кид Френс, Ту. По-Лец, инженер, мюзи-шин, синоматографер. В первый раз в 20-е сент. Они дремят свои идеи о фьючер,
这个神话部分源于他对戏剧性的天赋。这位俄罗斯先锋派艺术家将自己命名为“阿尔谢尼·阿夫拉の革命”（Réve Ars Avra，即阿尔谢尼·阿夫拉莫夫的革命）。他是法国人吗？不，他是列兵、工程师、音乐家、电影摄影师。第一次是在20世纪20年代。他们向未来、向革命、向阿夫拉莫夫、向世界、向新的时间、向革命、向新世界、向新的、新的、新的……展示他们的想法。他得到了某位高层的大力支持。他得到了托洛茨基的支持。据我所知，列宁也支持他。或者至少他容忍了这一切。他容忍这种赞美文化，将其作为创造这个新未来的一部分。这些先锋派艺术家和诗人们将向农民和工人传授艺术的未来。
с революшем, с ромовом и сцетом, в твое, сребенем, с революшем, с новым миром, с новым, с новым, с новым, He had very strong support from one high. He had support from Trotsky. And as far as I know, Lening supported him. Poor at least he tolerated it all. He tolerated this culture of praises as part of creating this new future. These artists, avant-gardeants and poets would teach the peasants and workers about the future of art.
在这个过程中，阿夫拉莫夫提出了影响深远的理论，勾勒出了电子音乐、生物力学以及早期在声音和电影中运用的概念。接着就是那部交响乐，阿夫拉莫夫未来的音乐《鸣笛交响乐》。这也是我来到这里的原因。1923年11月的那天，从红场阅兵的档案镜头中可以看到，天空晴朗，是一个寒冷的秋日。显然，那是克里姆林宫第一次被从飞机上拍摄。翻看录像带时，我找不到任何关于阿夫拉莫夫的证据，但斯米尔诺夫告诉我，讽刺的是，那位飞行员可能是唯一一个能看懂下面阿夫拉莫夫表演的人。
Along the way of Ramavud developed far-reaching theories that would sketch out the concepts of electronic music, biomechanics, early use of sound and cinema. And then there was the symphony and sirens of Rama's music of the future. The reason I'd come. The Archival footage of parades from Red Square that day in November 1923 showed clear skies a cold fall day It was the first time apparently the Kremlin had been filmed from an airplane Going through the tape I couldn't find any evidence of a ram of, but the irony, Smirnov told me, was that the pilot may have been the only one who could make sense of a ram's performance below.
交响乐的演出基本上没有引起注意，因为游行正在进行，我什么也听不见。没有人对正在发生的事情有丝毫的理解。那天我还了解到另一个细节。尽管1923年的演出没有任何录音留存，但几年前，圣彼得堡的一位年轻作曲家几乎重新排演了这首交响乐。我买了一张票，坐上了离开小镇的第一趟火车。我在彼得保罗要塞找到了谢尔盖·希斯特莫多夫（Sergei Kistmodov），他在那里向毫无防备的公众播放了汽笛的录音。希斯特莫多夫告诉我，阿夫拉莫夫相信每座城市都有它自己的交响乐。
The performance of the symphony went largely unnoticed, because demonstrations were going I don't hear a thing. And nobody had even the slightest understanding of what was going on. I'd learned one other detail that day. Although no recordings of the 1923 performance existed, a young composer in St. Petersburg had staged over almost symphony just a few years back. I bought a ticket and caught the first train out of town. I tracked down Sergei Histmodov on the Peter Paul Fortress, where he played a recording of the sirens to an unsuspecting public. His mod have told me that a ram of believed every city had its own symphony.
对于圣彼得堡，谢尔盖根据阿夫拉莫夫1923年总谱中的原始笔记构建了他的版本。古德科夫的交响乐被保存在档案中，我们可以在档案中阅读它，我们可以在某种程度上想象它，即使是用世界上最著名的语言。关于《鸣笛交响乐》，有一份详细的描述留存了下来。所以我们可以阅读它，并在脑海中想象它听起来会是什么样子。它告诉我们一切的顺序。什么时候拉响汽笛，什么时候鸣放礼炮，接下来应该发生什么？这是……
For St. Petersburg, Sergei had constructed his version according to Rama's own notes from the 1923 score. Symphonic Goodkov was preserved in a gas, we can read it in a gas, we can imagine it in a certain way, even in the most famous language in the world. With the symphony of sirens, a detailed description remains. So we can read it and hear what it might have sound like in our heads. It tells us the order of everything. When to turn on the sirens, when the cannons should fire, what should go afterwards? Which is this, a business which I am a jasmine choker.
这一切都写得清清楚楚，明明白白，显而易见为什么阿夫拉莫夫会这样做，这样这部交响乐不仅可以由音乐家演奏，还可以由任何识谱的人演奏。希斯特莫多夫将各种声音拼接在一起，从阿夫拉莫夫所谓的“主音响”开始——这是一组用来演奏工人圣歌《国际歌》的蒸汽汽笛。然后他加入了革命合唱团、飞机、喇叭、哨子、机枪、更多的喇叭、士兵，你懂的。它们共同构成了一种对苏联成就的工业赞歌，
It all spelled out and written down clearly, and it's obvious why a Vrama did it this way, so that the symphony could be played not only by musicians, but by any person who knew how to read. Kismat of Splice together sounds beginning with a Vrama so-called magistral, a set of steam whistle sirens constructed to play the workers' hymn, the international. Then he added revolutionary choirs and planes, horns, whistles, machine guns, more horns, soldiers, you get the idea. Collectively, they formed a sort of industrial hymn to Soviet achievement,
这座城市既是观众、表演者，也是舞台。在阿夫拉莫夫的讲述中，曾经充满压迫感的召唤工人劳动的汽笛，在工人国家里已经变成了值得庆祝的事物。那是未来的音乐，由大炮的轰鸣声发出信号。在汽笛交响乐演奏期间，阿夫拉莫夫站在挥舞着旗帜的屋顶上，指挥着每一个音色略有不同汽笛。随后，这首胜利的交响乐伴随着钟声持续了整整三分钟。声音非常大，正如希斯特莫多夫所言，汽笛吓坏了游客。汽笛吓坏了游客。我们继续在彼得保罗要塞周围散步，出乎意料的是，我们偶遇了一个关于美国作曲家约翰·凯奇的展览。
with the city united as audience, performer, and stage. In Ovramov's telling, the siren called to work, once so oppressive, had become something to celebrate in the workers' state. It was the music of the future, signaled by the cannon's roar. During the performance of the sirens, Avrama was up on the rooftop of the flags, telling each siren a little different in tone. And then this triumphant sonar was during out for another three minutes accompanying by bells. It was loud, his mouth was conceited, and the sirens scared the tourists. And the sirens scared the tourists. We continued our walk around pure Portrace when unexpectedly we came across an exhibit for the American composer John Cage.
他是一位先锋派艺术家，能在他周围的环境声音中听到音乐。在我看来，凯奇就像是晚出生几年、拿着不同护照的阿夫拉莫夫。这个巧合很奇怪。我们走了进去。我们走吧。然后遇到了叶莲娜·尼古拉耶夫娜。这并没有打动我，她说。在她看来，凯奇最大的“罪行”是他最著名的作品《4分33秒》，
And I'm on guard artist who'd heard music in the sounds of the environment around him. To my mind, Cage was a Vramov, born a few years later and with a different passport. The coincidence was odd. We entered. Let's go. And found Elena Nikolaevna. It doesn't move me, she said. In her view, Cage's biggest offense was his most famous work, four minutes and 33 seconds,
在这段时间里，没有任何音符被演奏。这首曲子由你那一刻身边的任何声音组成。叶莲娜·尼古拉耶夫娜坚持了四分钟，然后就放弃了。不如他们付给我150卢布呢，她说。我建议也许还有其他更合她口味的美国作曲家。不用了，谢谢，她说。如果那意味着更多像约翰·凯奇这样的人的话。我提到，但凯奇的想法并不是什么新鲜事。俄罗斯先锋派在20年代就已经探讨过这些相同的想法了。
in which no notes are played for that duration. The song consists of whatever sounds around you at that moment. Elen and Kalaim had lasted four minutes before she gave up. Better they pay me 150 rubles, she said. I suggest there might be other American composers more pleasing to her tastes. No, thank you, she said. Not if that meant more the likes of John Cage. But Cage's ideas weren't new, I mentioned. The Russian avant-garde had explored these same ideas in the 20s.
先锋派和苏联？希斯特莫多夫向她讲述了阿夫拉莫夫的想法。关于《鸣笛交响乐》。每个城市的交响乐。这就是彼得堡交响乐团的交响乐。是的，她说。彼得堡在歌唱。我们的城市就是一首交响乐。
Avant-garde and Soviet? Kiss-mod of told her about Ogramma's idea. About the symphony of sirens. The symphony for every city. That is the symphony of pravelle symphonic. Besterburg, which is... Yes, she said. Petersburg sings. Our city is a symphony.
没错。就好像那是她听过的最显而易见的事情一样。回到莫斯科后，我发现自己再次查看了红场的档案录像带。我仍然找不到阿夫拉莫夫，但这一次我被别的东西迷住了，其实是一个简单的想法。你永远无法回到最初。那天红场上的面孔充满了对一个新国家的兴奋。那里真的有骑自行车的男孩，但不久他们就会长大，奔赴战场，
That's right. As if it was the most obvious thing. She'd ever heard. Back in Moscow, I found myself reviewing the archival tapes from Red Square again. I still couldn't find a Vramov, but this time I was struck by something else, a simple idea really. You can never go back to the beginning. The faces on Red Square that day were full of excitement for a new country. There were literally boys on bicycles, but soon they would grow up, go to war,
我不禁想到许多人将无法归来。对阿夫拉莫夫来说，1923年11月是他最后一次尝试他的《鸣笛交响乐》。他没有成为苏联镇压的牺牲品，也没有在与纳粹的战斗中牺牲。据安德烈·斯米尔诺夫所说，阿夫拉莫夫和先锋派的其他成员只是被遗忘了。这个国家长大了，20世纪20年代狂野的雄心壮志让位给了苏联的官僚主义、停滞，以及最终的玩世不恭。问题在于，一半以上的公众
and I couldn't help but think that many wouldn't return. For Avramov, November 1923 was the last time he would attempt his symphony of sirens. He didn't fall victim to the Soviet repressions and he didn't die fighting the Nazis. According to Andrei Smirnov, Avramov and others from the avant-garde, they were just forgotten. The country grew up, and the wild ambitions of the 1920s gave way to Soviet officialdom, stagnation, and ultimately cynicism. The problem is that more than half of the public
根本不知道。这不仅关乎国家的存在，更关乎某种类似事物的存在的最重要部分。但问题是，绝大多数公众根本不知道。甚至不仅是意识到，而是关于是否有任何可能意识到类似的事情。曾经并没有，一切在当时都很好，这一切都曾存在过，这是我们本可以做到的，但事实并非如此。事实并非如此。这段20到30年代的历史非常重要。但这并不意味着身处其中的人们
just doesn't know. It's not just about the existence of the state, but the most important part of the existence of something that's similar. Но проблема в том, что больше часть публики просто не знает. Даже не только осозчитывания, но а самую вообще возможности осозчитывания, вот чего-то подобного. не было, что все хорошо было в вести, и все это было было, что мы могли сделать, но это не так. Но это не так. И эта история в 20-30-е, это очень важно. Но это значит, что люди, которые в них в них
在很多情况下，就像我们突然站起来一样，希望有一天这一切会改变。他们自己，他们付出了很多。这就像我们紧急站起来一样。总总之，总有一天这一切还是会发生的。无论如何，总会有那么一刻的。那天晚上，俄罗斯各地的城市上空响起了焰火。这是一个节日。我差点忘了。阿夫拉莫夫认为音乐是终极的公共体验，
могут быть в большом случае, это как мы встали, hopefully someday it will change. Они themselves, они очень много. Это как мы срочно встали. В общем, someday это будет что-то все-таки. Хоть когда-нибудь, но из инфинитса. That night fireworks rang out over cities all across Russia. It was a holiday. I'd almost forgotten. A Vrama thought music was the ultimate communal experience,
这让人很难不赞同。当时我们所有人都仰望天空中的烟花。但如果我闭上眼睛仔细倾听，我能听到汽车警报声、脚步声、欢笑声。然后我想象着城市的其他地方也加入进来，聚集抗议的人群、在隧道中疾驰的列车、莫斯科永无止境的交通，只是一天中这座城市的嗡嗡声和喧嚣。你不需要喜欢它作为未来的音乐
and it was hard not to agree. Here we all were looking skyward at the drums. But if I close my eyes and listen carefully, I could hear a car alarm steps on pavement, laughter. Then I imagined other parts of the city chiming in, crowds gathered in protests, trains racing in the tunnels, moscos never ending traffic, just the home and din of an average day in the city. You didn't have to like it when I was music of the future
也能知道它正在发生。如果我找不到这个人，嗯，知道音乐从未离开，这倒是一种安慰。以上是制作人查尔斯·迈因茨带给我们的重访《鸣笛交响乐》。这个故事是PRX呈现的全球故事项目的一部分，并得到了开放社会基金会的支持。在那篇报道中，提到了苏联设计，这让我想起了《99%隐形》早期的一集，我确信你们很多人都没有听过。
to know it was happening. And if I couldn't find the man, well, it was comforting to know that music had never left. That was the symphony of sirens revisited by producer Charles Meads. That story was part of the global story project presented by PRX with support from the Open Society Foundations. In that piece, there was a mention of Soviet design, and it brought to mind this early episode of 99% of visible that I'm sure many of you haven't heard.
所以我们决定把它附在这里供大家娱乐。你要问自己的问题是：你准备好向《Krugazor》的荣耀顶礼膜拜了吗？这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马斯。我的朋友朱莉娅·巴顿——也就是我——正和迈克尔·伊多夫在纽约的一间公寓里。我叫迈克尔·阿多夫，我是《俄罗斯制造：苏联设计的未被颂扬的偶像》一书的编辑。还有劳伦斯，一只模仿这栋楼门铃声惟妙惟肖的鹦鹉。不管我们怎么努力，
So we thought we'd just tack it on here for fun. The question you have to ask yourself is this, are you ready to bow down before the glory of Kroogazor? This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. My friend Julia Barton, that's me, is in a New York City apartment with Michael Idol. My name is Michael Adev, and I'm the editor of Maiden Russia, Unsung icons of Soviet design. And Lawrence, a parrot that sounds exactly like the building's door buzzer. And no matter how hard we try,
想要剪掉劳伦斯的声音。它对门铃的模仿是无法抗拒的。但也许这没关系，因为伊多夫关于苏联设计的新书是对普通苏联生活物品的致敬。香烟、饮水杯、地铁代币机，局外人可能很难看出这些看似随机的苏联消费品有什么共同点。
to cut out Lawrence. His door buzzer imitation cannot be denied. But maybe that's okay, because Adolf's new book on Soviet design is an homage to the stuff of ordinary Soviet life. Cigarettes, drinking glasses, subway token machines, and it might be hard for outsiders to see what this seemingly random collection
但伊多夫相信，某种东西将它们全部联系在了一起。要定义这种美学，你首先需要意识到，这些物品大多是不同质量的西方产品的劣质山寨品。它们是模仿品。就像鹦鹉劳伦斯模仿门铃一样。闭嘴，劳伦斯。
of Soviet consumer goods have in common. But Idov believes there's something that unites them all. To define this aesthetic, you first need to realize that most of these items were rip offs of Western sources of varying qualities. They are imitations. Like the way Lawrence the parrot is imitating the door buzzer. Shut up, Lawrence.
只要看一眼这本书里的物品，尽管它们是毫无廉耻的模仿，但你会发现这些苏联的东西带有无可否认的苏联特色。以你们的苏联苏打水机为例。在那些机器里，碳酸饮料不是装在瓶子里，而是直接流入一个公共饮水杯中，那个杯子是用链子拴在机器上的。而那些极度折磨人的苏联街机游戏是由游乐委员会设计的。大多数美国人甚至没见过这些文物，但在某种程度上，我们要为它们负责。
One look at the items in this book, even though they are shameless imitations, you'll see that the Soviet stuff is unmistakably Soviet. Take your Soviet soda machine. In those, carbonated drinks came not in bottles, but straight into a communal drinking glass, something chained to the machine. And the excruciating Soviet arcade games were designed by the Committee on Amusement. Most Americans haven't even seen these artifacts, but in a way, we're responsible for them.
基本上这一切都可以追溯到厨房辩论。1959年，美国在莫斯科举办了一场空前成功的展览。这是美国博览会的正式开幕，它是苏联在纽约贸易展的对应活动，致力于展示我们国家最高的生活标准。副总统尼克松带着苏联总理尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫参观了展览，他们在美式郊区住宅的模型前停下来，在一台崭新的美国彩色电视机摄像机前向观众发表讲话。在某些情况下，你们可能走在我们前面。例如，在发展你们的、用于探索太空的火箭推力方面。
Basically it all goes back to the kitchen debates. In 1959 there was this wildly successful American exhibit in Moscow. It's the official opening of the American Exposition, counterpart of the Soviet trade show in New York, and dedicated to showcasing the highest standard of life in our country. Vice President Nixon showed Soviet premier Nikita Krushchev around the exhibit, and they stopped in front of a model suburban home to address an audience before new American color TV cameras. There are some instances where you may be ahead of us. For example, in the development of your, of the thrust of your rockets for the investigation
在某些情况下，例如彩色电视，可能是我们走在你们前面。但为了我们双方，为了我们双方，你，为了我们双方，你永远不可能看得更好。迈克尔·艾多夫说，尽管赫鲁晓夫大放厥词，加之“斯普特尼克”号最近取得成功，苏联人还是被美国人的所有这些东西羞辱了。赫鲁晓夫决定苏联人民也需要这些东西。但对于共产党来说，要将苏联工厂从生产坦克和火箭转向生产盒式磁带录音机和吹风机，是一场巨大的斗争。
about our space. There may be some instances, for example, color television, where we're ahead of you. But in order for both of us, for both of us, you, for both of us, you never could see it any better. Michael Aydov says that despite Khrushchev's bombast and the recent success of Sputnik, the Soviets were humiliated by all of America's stuff. Chrisch have decided the Soviet people needed stuff too. But it was a huge struggle for the Communist Party to switch Soviet factories from producing tanks and rockets to cassette decks and hair dryers.
通常的工作方式是，某个党内官员从国外旅行回来，带回一台德国收音机，把它交给工程师说“照着做一个”，然后他们就会对其进行逆向工程，接着他们在周围找一个（你知道的）画得不错的人，对他说：“好吧，你能画画吗？行，你来设计个logo。”然后那个logo就会使用接下来的40年。这个系统生产了很多奇怪的东西，但有时苏联人做得比原版还要好。来看看那本酷炫得令人难以置信的杂志《Krugazor》。
Usually the way it worked was some party guy would come back from a foreign trip and bring in a German radio and give it to the engineers and say make one like it and then they would just reverse engineer it and then they would look around for you know the guy who draws well and they're like all right well can you draw okay you do the logo and that would be the logo that would last for the next 40 years. The system produced a lot of strange stuff, but sometimes the Soviets did better than the original. Take the unbelievably cool magazine, Krugazor.
不，每个人都应该向《Krugazor》的荣耀顶礼膜拜。据说它的灵感来自于赫鲁晓夫在美国时看到的东西——一本带有唱片插页的杂志。伊多夫称之为最初的播客。它听起来真的很像公共广播。杂志上会有一篇文章，然后黑胶唱片里的内容会以某种方式说明这篇文章，你知道的，会有森林的声音或者诸如此类的内容，或者某个遥远部落的民歌。或者这个。
No, everybody should just bow down to further glory of Krugazor. It was supposedly based on something Kruschev saw while in the United States, a magazine with a record in it. I love calls it the original podcast. It actually sounds like public radio. There would be an article in the magazine and then the contents of the vinyl desk would somehow illustrate the article, you know, there would be the sounds of the forest or something like that, or folk songs of some far-flung tribe. Or this. We, the fight for the ride, to be free, and we,
随着时间的推移，发生的事情是，你知道的，由于制作这本杂志的人能够接触到某种对苏联来说绝对无与伦比的绝妙东西，制作这本杂志的人能够接触到某种对苏联来说好得难以置信的东西，那就是：黑胶压片机。他们开始在里面塞进一点流行音乐。正是《Krugazor》杂志里的那些圆形撕拉式唱片，让俄罗斯人听到了从芭芭拉·史翠珊、平克·弗洛伊德到迈克尔·杰克逊等各路艺人的第一批非盗版录音。
build out of it. What started happening over time was, you know, since the people who made this magazine had access to something, you know, undilulably awesome for the Soviet Union, So the people who made this magazine had access to something, you know, unbelievably awesome for the Soviet Union, which is, you know, a vinyl of a press. They started slipping in a little pop music in there. It was the round tearout discs in Krukazor that gave Russians their first non-bootleg recordings
《俄罗斯制造》中的设计最主要共同点在于，它们往往是唯一的选择。迈克尔·艾多夫从书架上成堆的各种盒式磁带录音机中挑选，比如Vesna。БК电子微型计算机，凭借其纯粹的糟糕程度，大概让说俄语的黑客成为了世界上最厉害的人。没有人有别的选择。
of everyone from Barbra Streisand to Pink Floyd to Michael Jackson. The main thing that unites the designs in Made in Russia is that they're often the only designs. Michael I'd often pick from shelf loads of, say, different cassette recorders. Most Soviets had one, the Visna. In the BK Electronic Up Personal Computer, probably made Russian speaking hackers the best in the world through its sheer awfulness. Nobody had any other choice.
我绝不是说这实际上是一件好事，但它确实简化了彼此了解的过程，因为如果你是在苏联长大的，而且和我年龄相仿或更大，我对你已经了解得太多了。包括那首伴你入眠的歌曲。如果你是在苏联长大的，它已经深深烙印在你的脑海里。如果你想听，我可以为你唱。它是怎么唱的来着？
Farbeid from me to suggest that this is actually a good thing, but it certainly simplifies getting to know one another because if you grew up in the Soviet Union and you're my age or older, I already know so much about you. Including the song that put you to bed at night. If you grew up in the Soviet Union, it's just seared into your brain. I can sing it for you if you want. How does it go?
我想它是这样的。这段旋律来自苏联电视台每天晚上8点15分播出的儿童木偶戏主题曲。你不能真正把那些粗糙的动物木偶称为苏联设计的偶像，但艾多夫还是把它们收录进了他的书里。因为带着明亮的眼睛和磨损的皮毛，小猪鲁莎和兔子斯捷帕什卡代表了一个失落的宇宙。一个与世界其他地方隔绝了11个时区的世界，用他们自己的方式制造着他们自己的东西。
I think it goes. This theme from a children's puppet show aired every night at 815 on Soviet television. You can't really call the crude animal puppets, icons of Soviet design, but I don't put them in his book anyway. Because with their bright eyes and worn out for,ruysha the Pig and Stepashka the Bunny represent a lost universe. 11 time zones closed off from the rest of the world, making their own stuff in their own way.
疲惫的玩具现在正在睡觉。歌词就是这样唱的。晚安，罗曼。“99%隐形”由萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯制作。《重访鸣笛交响乐》由查尔斯·迈因茨制作，《苏联设计的未被颂扬的偶像》由朱莉娅·巴顿制作。我们是旧金山本地公共广播KALW的91.7项目，以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。所以请访问“99%隐形”。你必须访问99pi.org。
The tired toys are sleeping now. That's how the song goes. Good night, Roman. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. The symphony of sirens revisited was produced by Charles Mainz and the unsung icons of Soviet design was produced by Julia Barton. We're a project 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. So it's up to 99% invisible. You must go to 99pi.org.
本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
[♪ BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING,INGING,INGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING,INGING, BELL RINGING There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
[♪ 铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响铃，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，响起，响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，铃声响起，响起，铃声响起] 本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。